- Sara, who do you think is the most...
You know, most likely to trip?
- Well, I don't know.
I guess, I would agree
that, you know,
I think we all have really clumsy moments.
(Kelly laughing)
I'm honest, it pops in my mind
when Busy hit Renee in the
face with a salad bowl.
- What?
- Yes.
- Wait, what'd you do?
- Oh my God. I almost forgot.
- We... We had some-
- We were shooting a scene in a closet,
and there was a gag
where she was supposed
to, you know, spill...
toss the salad as it were.
And the next thing I
know, I was like, "God!"
- Oh my gosh. Okay, so then it-
- Wait.
- The shot of me talking
like this is still in it.
- Well, it was-
- But the best part
was Renee asking us like,
"You, guys is it bad?
Is it bad?"
And it's like her lip is
like four times the size.
And we're just like, "No, it's fine."
- Lying.
- "It looks great. It
looks totally normal.
It's totally normal."
- They're all lying.
No. Just keep acting
- And I, I walked in after
the whole thing happened
and it was a very weird energy on the set.
Everyone was whispering.
She got a giant bag of ice
on her face and Busy was
kind of pacing around.
- See, this is what I imagined.
Girl groups are like, I know
you can't laugh until later
but then you laugh hysterically
because you've been
holding it for a minute.
Cause you want it to laugh before.